hallo leute vor ein paar monaten haben
wir auf diesem kanal schon einmal ein
video darüber gemacht wie man im
deutschen höflicher klingen kann damals
ging es um bitten und aufforderungen und
wir haben euch erklärt wie man zum
beispiel den konjunktiv nutzen kann um
im deutschen höflicher zu klingen wenn
man eine bitte formuliert dieses video
könnt ihr hier oben sehen und heute
reden wir auch darüber wie man etwas
höflicher formulieren kann und heute
geht es um das thema fragen im deutschen
gibt es nämlich direkte und indirekte
fragen und eine direkte frage wäre zum
beispiel wann kommt der bus eine
indirekte folge wäre können sie mir
sagen wann der bus kommt und diese
indirekten fragen die können manchmal
dabei helfen wenn man etwas höflicher
formulieren möchte und wann man die
benutzt und wie man die bildet das
erklären wir euch im heutigen video los
geht's
[Musik]
wie die passe kundenservice corinna am
telefon wie kann ich ihnen helfen ja wo
ist mein paket
guten tag erstmal wie ist denn die
sendungsnummer ja woher soll ich das
wissen die steht in ihrer
bestellbestätigung
moment 8 d
zhw vw
81 coves
das paket hat heute das logistikzentrum
verlassen und wann kommt das an das kann
ich ihnen leider nicht so genau sagen na
toll danke für gar nichts
auf wiederhören
hier habt ihr gerade ein ziemlich
unfreundliches gespräch gehört deutsche
sind natürlich ein bisschen dafür
bekannt dass sie manchmal ein bisschen
direkt und unfreundlich sind aber in
diesem gespräch habt ihr tatsächlich
auch sehr viele direkte fragen gehört
und das ist etwas was vielleicht janisch
am anfang falsch gemacht hat im gespräch
er hat direkt gefragt hallo wo ist mein
paket das ist eine sehr direkte frage
und dadurch hat auch vielleicht das
ganze gespräch eine sehr direkte und
unfreundliche richtung genommen und man
kann das tatsächlich etwas höflicher
formulieren wenn man in direkte fragen
benutzt indirekte fragen muss man nicht
immer benutzen ist es durchaus okay dass
man unter freunden eine direkte frage
stellt aber es ist ein stilmittel das
man benutzen kann wenn man zum beispiel
mit fremden oder am telefon oder
vielleicht mit respektperson entspricht
und hier seht ihr jetzt die gleiche oder
fast die gleiche konversation noch mal
aber mit indirekten fragen und ihr könnt
mal hören ob ihr diesen unterschied seht
[Musik]
speedy passe kundenservice corinna am
telefon wie kann ich ihnen helfen
guten tag mein name ist yanofsky ich
möchte gerne wissen soll ein paket ist
da helfe ich gerne können sie mir sagen
wie die sendungsnummer lautet wo finde
ich denn diese industrie die steht in
der bestellbestätigung
momente
8 d
zhw vw acht sie als schaaf es ist im
moment
das paket hat heute das logistikzentrum
verlassen
und wissen sie vielleicht waren das
paket ankommt
das kann ich ihnen leider nicht so genau
sagen ich hoffe bald
na gut trotzdem danke gerne ich hoffe
dass ihr paket bald ankommt auf
wiederhören danke das hoffe ich auch auf
wiederhören
in der letzten szene habt ihr plötzlich
ein viel freundlicheres gespräch gehört
und der grund dafür ist dass janisch
hier mit einer indirekten frage
angefangen hat und ihr seht dann im
ganzen gespräch mehr in direkte fragen
als direkte fragen in direkte fragen
sind also ein super mittel um in einem
gespräch höflicher zu klingen und wie
man die eigentlich bildet das erklären
wir euch jetzt
in direkte fragen bildet man indem man
die eigentliche frage in einem nebensatz
stellt ich zeige euch jetzt noch mal ein
beispiel
ja wo ist mein paket
wo ist mein paket ist die direkte frage
und es ist ein hauptsatz mit einer sehr
einfachen struktur ihr habt das frage
wort wo das verb ist und das objekt mein
paket die indirekte frage bildet man
jetzt in dem man diesen hauptsatz zu
einem nebensatz macht hier seht ihr mal
das beispiel
ich möchte gerne wissen wohl ein paket
ist in
diesem satz könnt ihr immer noch diesen
satz wo ist mein paket finden aber er
ist jetzt ein nebensatz das heißt er ist
dem hauptsatz untergeordnet der
hauptsatz ist jetzt ich möchte gerne
wissen und der nebensatz ist wo mein
paket ist dadurch klingt die frage nicht
mehr so direkt und sie ist etwas
höflicher geworden hier zeige ich euch
noch ein beispiel
dann kommt der bus
in zehn minuten ok
entschuldigung wissen sie vielleicht
wann der bus kommt ja in zehn minuten ok
danke
auch in diesem beispiel habt ihr gesehen
wie eine indirekte frage höflicher
klingen kann als die direkte frage die
hamas hat gefragt wann kommt der bus
sehr direkt in der indirekten frage hat
er gesagt können sie mir sagen wann der
bus kommt dadurch ist die frage
untergeordnet im nebensatz sie klingt
ein bisschen höflicher eine wichtige
sache ist also wenn man eine indirekte
frage bildet das man diesen rahmen
bilden muss man muss also einen
hauptsatz finden und die eigentliche
frage im nebensatz stellen und so ein
hauptsatz kann zb sein ich möchte gerne
wissen ob oder können sie mir sagen wann
oder wissen sie vielleicht was das sind
also alles so typische rahmen fragen die
man benutzen kann wenn man eine
indirekte frage formulieren möchte
übrigens wenn ihr jetzt mal selber üben
möchte wie man so eine indirekte frage
bildet dann guckt euch doch mal unsere
interaktiven übungen zu diesem thema an
easy und eric aus unserem segment ihm
bereiten nämlich jede woche interaktive
übungen zu all unseren videos vor und
damit könnt ihr noch etwas intensiver
lernen und dann auch selbst aktiv werden
wenn ihr das ausprobieren möchtet dann
werdet einfach ein mitglied von the
german ein mitglied werden könnte schon
ab 5 euro pro monat ihr könnt jederzeit
kündigen und das einfach mal
ausprobieren und gleichzeitig
unterstützt er mit der mitgliedschaft
unsere arbeit
jetzt konnten wir uns mal die
satzstruktur dieser indirekten fragen
genauer an und wir beginnen mit den
sogenannten w-fragen w fragen sind die
die anfangen mit solchen frage wörtern
wie wo wann wie wer was also alle frage
wörter mit w johannes hat gefragt wann
kommt der bus die indirekte variante war
wissen sie vielleicht wann der bus kommt
der satz bleibt sehr ähnlich man behält
dieses frage wort und das frage- wort
wird eigentlich zu einer art konjunktion
im satz man sagt wissen sie vielleicht
wann der bus kommt was man also macht
ist eigentlich nur das verb verändern
die position des werbe zurück nach
hinten wie in jedem satz steht das
konjugierte verb jetzt am ende und das
ist auch schon alles was man wissen muss
bei diesen sogenannten w fragen in der
indirekten frage wird das weh oder das
frage wort einfach zur konjunktion und
das konjugierte wert rückt ans ende
[Musik]
da die bis heute abend zu hause ja prima
heute abend kommt endlich mein paket du
musst es annehmen klar mache ich
in unserem letzten beispiel gucken wir
uns ja nein fragen an ja nein fragen
heißen ja nein fragen weil man sie mit
ja oder nein beantworten kann und sie
beginnen meistens mit einem werk in der
letzten szene hat janisch mich gefragt
bist du heute abend zu hause das war die
direkte variante und jetzt schauen wir
uns mal die indirekte variante dieser
frage an
k wie ich muss unbedingt wissen ob du
heute abend zu hause bist ja ich glaube
schon klima heute kommt endlich mein
paket du musst es annehmen ok mache ich
in diesem beispiel habt ihr gesehen wie
man aus einer ja nein frage eine
indirekte frage macht janisch hat gesagt
ich muss unbedingt wissen ob du heute
abend zu hause bist eine ja nein frage
wird also immer mit einem abgebildet
wenn man sie indirekt formuliert ich
kann also sagen gehst du morgen mit ins
kino das ist die direkte variante und
die indirekte variante ist ich würde
gerne wissen ob du morgen mit mir ins
kino gest der rest der satzstruktur
bleibt gleich wie bei den anderen setzen
auch ist das konjugierte verb im
nebensatz am ende
fassen wir noch mal alles was wir heute
gelernt haben zusammen erstens indirekte
fragen sind ein stilmittel das man dann
benutzen kann wenn man etwas höflicher
klingen möchte zweitens indirekte fragen
sind ganz einfach zu bilden man rückt
einfach die frage die eigentliche frage
in einen nebensatz und drittens wenn man
das macht verändert sich die
satzstruktur ganz leicht man hat also
jetzt einen nebensatz dieser nebensatz
wird entweder mit einer b mit einem wort
oder mit einem ob eingeleitet und das
coni bergstedt jetzt in der frage im
nebensatz hinten wenn ihr dieses video
nützlich findet zum deutsch lernen dann
freuen wir uns sehr wenn ihr unseren
kanal abonniert hier unten vielleicht
aktiviert ihr auch die klingel und dann
bekommt ihr immer eine nachricht wenn
wir ein neues video herausbringen und
wenn ihr noch tiefer einsteigen möchte
in das deutsch lernen dann empfehlen wir
euch die easy german mitgliedschaft als
mitglied unterstützt die unsere arbeit
und gleichzeitig bekommt ihr zu all
unseren videos und podcasts episoden
zusätzliche lernmaterialien tschüss und
bis bald
kali ist das mein paket ja
halt
[Applaus]
rocking 2000